ces visites programmées comme
très souvent je me déplace dans
l'académie en l'occurrence à le voir à
la fois l'école primaire et le collège
donc après il ya la vie de l'école
primaire effectivement chez venu au
collège comme c'était prévu et donc j'ai
rencontré effectivement les manifestants
il ya pas de raison que je n'aime pas et
surtout que je ne discute pas avec eux
donc sur leurs revendications et puis
d'échanger sur leurs sur leur ressenti
sur la situation qu'il a fallu
effectivement lors leur expliquer qu'il
y avait tout un programme de
revalorisation dernier à sion par le
biais effectivement des primes que ça
c'était à la fois une nécessité pour un
recalage par rapport aux collègues
européens mais une nécessité également
pour assurer et garantir surtout un
niveau de retraite identique à celui qui
existe aujourd'hui pour